[Musique]
m
samedi soir f sur az au luxembourg on y
va quand on a 17 ans et qu'on habite
ville rue de l'autre côté de la
frontière
soit un certain jacky
tout a commencé il ya cent ans
avec les grands-parents venus d'italie
de pologne pour y trouver du travail
maintenant pour les dix mille ouvriers
la population active de villerupt le
travail est devenu un problème des
usines ferment
à quel âge vous avez commencé à
travailler à temps elle faisait des
journées de combien de voix la journée
pourquoi tu es qu elles étaient douze
heures six ascenseurs et puis après vous
rentriez j'ai voulu à la maison non je
venais se coucher pour leur travail vous
vous êtes jamais révolter contre ce
travail vous avez jamais non non on ne
pourrait pas si tu as besoin elle
s'était il fallait qu'il fallait que sur
route sur voulez moi j'ai il fallait
qu'on travaille c'est pas comme
maintenant
non ça serait moins et puis après vous
avez rencontré votre femme
reid hoballah but est juste au dessus
parce qu'elles habitaient pas loin où
vous l'avez rencontré comme ça dans
l'escalier bon se connaissaient les
familles se connaissaient déjà et vous
l'avez vu la première fois vous êtes
prêt sera mon mari oui ça a été un petit
peu qu'autour d'eux mêmes gens n'y
croient pas
dans ses mémoires il pleuvrait lors du
toujours plus est marié à quel âge
j'avais 20 ans
25 et puis vous avez des enfants
oui deux ans après deux jumeaux les dix
ans après une petite fille satisfaction
personnelle
claude 18 ans l'un des jumeaux
dire que c'est des mauvaises enfance
c'est pas loin seulement depuis trois
ans ils ont rasé des voix qui nous
échappe
l usine travail près de vous bah oui
l'histoire ya mes yeux j'aime pas que
les enfants aillent à pépé qui sont
indépendants elle supplante travail des
quatre ans mais je pense qu'il faut que
j'aille jusqu'à 60 ans jallet voit
jamais michel 18 ans l'autre du monde
c'est pas qu'ils ont rien fait je ne
demande rien pour moi moi ce que
j'aurais voulu se faire pour eux mais
j'ai travaillé et puis j'arrivais à rien
donc c'est pas de satisfaction pour moi
sabine et dimanche à peu jamais jamais
j'aurais jamais acheter un costume
savent pas ce que c'est un costume
[Musique]
alors des fois alors dû mais c'est nous
qu'on a honte au casse la tête toi tu
dis
après moi qui chante et j'étais
impeccable parce que mais ça aussi ça
vient beaucoup de défis liés parce que
les loups dans le temps quand on allait
au bal si vous n'habitez une jeune je
suis à danser plus regardée de boire si
vous étiez bien habillé est ce que
maintenant c'est le contraire s'il est
bien habillé il est repoussé
soit disant parce que c'est que me
raconte donc ça vient de la femme a
commencé leur vie sentimentale
c'est plus pareil que non en plus elle
plus de liberté vous avez de chaque côté
par exemple du côté de la fille comme du
côté des gars pour monsieur thériault
les jumeaux vient d'une autre planète
il travaille un jour sur deux ils ont
les cheveux longs il échappe leur
évasion
cette mine désaffectée les buts rouge
qu'ils appellent le bois tu contactes
pas ces gens là je peux pas dire ils
sont bonnes et son mauvais départ l'a vu
par la vue on voit que quand même c'est
beaucoup plus de libérer entre les
garçons des filles c'est plus de
l'amitié qui comme nous avons c'était
pas pareil
par exemple de personnes fréquentent et
youtube ont investi ensemble aux poses
plus ou moins éviter de les traîner
parler que nous avec l'aude est ce que
maintenant ils sortent subir avec une
niche en coop avec lotus et accapare
tant qu'elle jean qui pensent à moi la
musique ne chantes tu prends boulot quoi
tu vois
sûrement pas au boulot c'est à suivre
heureux tout simplement si j'arrive à
ses parents
[Musique]
moi c'est ce que je fais dans la vie ce
ne sera pas un travail ce sera un loisir
comprendre ça sera ça sera j'essaierai
de trouver quelque chose qui quelque
chose de vraiment bien qu'ils ne soient
pas ce travail toi je vois pas comme le
travail toi ça sera quelque chose de
sang froid de s'approcher au coeur de le
faire toi mais quand tu penses à ton
père par exemple
oui quand tu penses à ton père qui
travaille depuis depuis quarante ans et
qui est fier de son travail
il a toujours travaillé en usine qui ne
peut pas se détacher de lusine tôt il
publiait de travailler était obligé pour
nourrir ses enfants toit s'est pas
plaint d'avoir des enfants pour les
faire mourir de faim toi il m'a dit
comme ça qu'à 25 ans lui aussi voulu
faire beaucoup de choses ce soir il va
beaucoup de choses et puis en fin de
compte il n'a pas pu faire parce que il
s'est marié
après il s'est dit que fois qu'il serait
marié bas ce serait fini tu vois ces
revues d'art est à 20 ans ça c'est pas
bon c'est à vie jusqu'à l'amour peut pas
dire que je pourrais pas dire qu'il ait
mon amour non mais quand même toi c'est
pas une vie avec quel genre de femme
douce art et ça nous donne un peu
d'argent ou alors complètement opposées
donc si c'est qu'on vous pose c'est à
dire pendant longtemps à moins de
sorties cnam entière c'est une fille
vachement bien parlez pas à moi et toi
tu allais pas me parlait pas un mot de
français et le mariage c'est quoi pour
vous
idiot tu peux pas trouver de 60 ans
jusqu'en fin moyenne 200 ans tenteront
60 ans et sa fille toi tu représentes un
peu ce que ça fait du jour au lendemain
ça c'est trop c'est trop
pas possible d'estimer d'autres coins de
vivre avec une efficacité problème tu
diras pas eu deux enfants
si un enfant est d'accord vous le temps
si je me m'arrive est ouest entre est
quand même le coup de de faire une
existence plus ou moins longue avec la
fille tu vois avant le mariage tort
c'est quand même quelque chose un peu
mieux
[Musique]
e